Bad Bunny and Kendall Jenner's romance
isn't hitting the brakes anytime soon
it's really exciting that's the model
and singer on a night date heading out
of Tyler the Creator's concert in LA
both keeping their looks casual Kenny
rocking yoga pants a hoodie and baseball
cap while Bad Bunny Sports a T-shirt and
sneakers
[Music]
at one point the couple hopped into the
rapper's three million dollar Bugatti
Kenny right by his side as bunny takes
the driver's seat both laughing as they
try to move past other cars like oh my
God just be cool it's fine but this
isn't the first time bad Bunny's giving
Kenny a ride
look out
[Music]
the rapper took her on a wild ride
through the Coachella fairgrounds in a
golf cart the day after she supported
him as he made history as the first
Latino solo artist to headline the Music
Festival
I always
put my piece of my heart on everything
that I do Bad Bunny and Kendall began
fueling romance rumors in February since
then they've shown PDA on a sushi date
and most recently enjoyed a romantic
horseback ride together goodbye
happiness nothing anything complicated
at the time source told E.T that the two
are attracted to each other and have a
flirty Vibe but simply they're enjoying
each other's company and like each other
well what kind of qualities are you
looking for in a relationship be honest
always be honest it's not always easy
but I don't know I just kind of I like
to keep my private life pretty private
so
I try my best but at the same time I
don't I don't like to let being seen out
in public with someone like affect my
everyday life so what are the chances
fans will see Bad Bunny and Kenny's
romance play out on the Kardashians
season three it all comes back to
protecting my piece unlikely but hey you
never know just from a really young age
I think both Kylie and I kind of knew
what we wanted to keep off the show or
what we wanted to keep to ourselves and
I think that it's kind of as simple as
that and you know we learn and again our
boundaries may change one day depending
on the situation but yeah
foreign